first off off the top out the gate thank
you very much to curiosity stream for
sponsor in this video I'm gonna having
fun with the documentary videos and
we'll talk a little more about them
later but first some Jumanji mayhem
let's review that
[Music]
Jumanji the next level so Jumanji the
next levels the sequel to Jumanji
welcome to the jungle we have the
returning cast Dwayne Johnson Jack Black
Heron Gillan Kevin Hart and this time
there's a new was a new mechanic same
mechanic new gimmick long story short
they're not necessarily in the same
bodies as before so now the actors have
to do new things I thought that was
really cool probably more fun for them
it's enjoyable for you to see how they
interpret the other character I mean I
like a first and foremost the movies
funny being a comedy pretty important I
was laughing in the movie Kevin Hart and
Jack Black man dude see moments like
this are why I argue when people say old
Kevin Hart sucks he's not funny I find
the dude to be really talented really
funny he's not always in good things but
even in those movies that might be bad
you can tell is like alright you got a
paycheck but I could still see you got
it I can still see something there and
you totally see it here in terms of the
impersonations that have to do Jack
Black and Kevin Hart man at first the
rock I was like is that is that the
voice you should be doing I was like oh
he's doing Cuckoo's Nest I get it it
makes more sense now granted the movie's
a sequel we already know the rules that
was the enjoyment in the first movie
this is surprisingly enjoyable oh I
guess the first movie is actually the
second movie welcome to the jungle that
says that's the second movie what is
that movie you know it was neat finding
out about all the lives they have on
their arms they only have three of them
okay so you already know those rules so
this movie has to amp it up and be like
alright there are new things you need to
figure out there are new mechanics and
they sought to play with the old rules
point is I felt like this movie did what
sequels do which is get a bit zany I had
fun for the most part but there was a
point where I was like I feel like I'm
in an improv comedy club right now looks
like alright you're doing this all sweet
all right now you to swap and you have
to do that alright you to swap there was
one mechanic in particular this movie
kept messing with and credit it was fun
seeing the actors play with it it was
fun seeing Kevin Hart have to do that
and that Jack Black doing that and that
so if you're looking at it with like oh
how fun are the actors having it looks
like a lot of fun but as for a movie
being cohesive I felt like the movie was
playing ping-pong it didn't know where
to commit and I felt like this was
happening because well it's a sequel and
the sequels have to do more it has to be
bigger and is bigger better well as the
question I don't mean to sound like I'm
bagging on the movie I don't mean for
that to be the case the movies pretty
much what you probably thought the movie
would be
you enjoyed the first second Jumanji
movie welcome to the jungle that is is
it as focused and clean as the previous
movie now but is it a fun adventure yes
for the most part did the movie make me
laugh
yes I laughed quite a few times in this
movie and those things make me forgive
the moments I felt like the movie was
going Looney Tunes because they felt
like the audience was getting bored so
they had to do say anything at all at
all I'll say I had a good time no
alcohol required as mentioned earlier
this video is brought to you by
curiosity stream curiosity stream is the
world's first subscription streaming
service that offers thousands of
documentary videos as I've said before
on here I love a good documentary video
I love quenching that thirst for
knowledge how we all love it right
there's a series on curiosity stream
called dream the future with an episode
called entertainment of the future not
gonna live Jumanji was the thing I'd get
it I totally do it you don't even lie
you would so click the link below to go
to curiosity stream comm slash Jones
enter promo code Jon's been signing up
get your first 30 days free of curiosity
stream and for a limited time annual
plans and gift cards still 40% on Black
Friday and over on my watch that so
thank you once again the curiosity
stream for sponsoring this video
I do appreciate it no Jumanji the next
level have you seen it watch it you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]